all right says we're live here we are
again
it's Wednesday yeah give it a few
seconds to buzz it has a hard time
starting it does how are you did
damn red line there we go there is I
wanted to do a couple shout outs before
because I forgot to do one yesterday we
got a new heavy hitter patron named
Terry so I wanted to say thank you very
much to Terry also sent me a very nice
message and she watches it with her
daughter so that's really cool also if
you look behind us ladies and gentlemen
yeah yeah our friend Sophie she gave me
a birthday present it was a to Frank
Frazetta on arm on canvas the night kick
ass yes it's just called the Barbarian
we know that shit's [ __ ] Konad but he
probably couldn't say Conan for
licensing reasons but Frank did a lot of
the cover art for Conan novels yeah so
property Howard erotica yeah it was yeah
he did him later when they were
releasing them so I don't know if I'm a
big fan of Frazetta
and yeah I mean that he draws and the
dude [ __ ] is super super heroic
everything was like heroic and has just
waited into the max yeah they kind of
not all of them but everybody is like I
don't want to say superhuman but damn
near yeah damn
and it's just pictures of humans doing
what they do best [ __ ] [ __ ] up
[ __ ] [ __ ] is protected stuff taking
stuff trying to keep stuff from being
taken away it's just that's the kind of
themes I like yeah but yeah we just
decided I mean we kind of were like
where are we gonna put it where we're
gonna put it then we're like yeah put it
right there on the show so what's always
in the background yeah nicer than what
we had back there yeah I guess but got
light on it and everything I know it's
awesome well uh we'll talk about that
again when we have cuz like I said I
know not everybody watches like these
shorter like matinee ones we just like
to do these and they'll never be caught
up with whatever that we're doing so all
right so we go to watch
hey hey hey clay hey mango badger yeah
man go bad Badgers in so as I said we
were like whoa okay we were gonna watch
a new movie last night no I did want to
see the best of night but we don't have
Amazon Prime and it wasn't like four it
wasn't for rent on youtube or on Xbox or
anything oh I kind of flipped through
and I couldn't really find anything that
looked horribly you know interesting so
I gave the reins over to Tom oh [ __ ] and
we're never doing that well see this I I
like to let you pick the movies because
then if you hate it then you can't like
this and mode because you're the one
that picked it out okay so look in the
horror section look at the horror
section on Xbox yeah there wasn't a
whole bunch of [ __ ] in there that we
haven't seen already and on the bottom
of it was like about three or four at
the bottom of list that's it that's a
bad sign usually but at the bottom of
the list for the new ones was like three
clown movies and we looked at what are
the at the trailer for this one and the
trailer looked pretty good I was like
that'd be yeah yeah the first the first
trailer we watched was for what it
wasn't a clown movie but it didn't we
watch the trailer for Antichrist rising
or anything like that that wasn't it
really like it got made on someone's
phone I don't know if I really want to
say that it might not have been that one
but I just remember that so then like we
we scroll through and there is like
another killer clown movie and I think
like killer clown movies are almost
getting up there with like we J and
shark movies where it's just like
there's so many yeah that you know
everybody it's like I've probably made a
killer clown movie and it not even aware
of it because there's so many so oh
thank you very much making for the
clinic
yeah so we see one and it's at the very
bottom like I don't know when they rank
the movies I don't know if it's ranked
by the date it came out or how popular
it is like how many people are running
it but this one was the very very last
one in the horror movie section and this
one was called clown fear clown fear
yeah and the trailer actually looked the
trailer actually looks like it's like
fun it looks like a good time
like it was gonna be like a throwback
kind of 80s type of movie but then it
started we watch this movie was a
[ __ ] abomination really bad I mean
usually a bad movie can kind of keep my
attention this one couldn't even really
keep my attention yeah I think I did
stuff at some point
what they did was is they used they used
every bit of footage that they [ __ ]
shot
clearly all right the movie was probably
what nearly two hours long it was an
hour and 49 minutes which is I mean
that's generally too long for any horror
movie there are exceptions obviously but
for a horror movie like this that's way
too long it had a huge cast lots and
lots of [ __ ] just unneeded scenes and
unnecessary dialogue the [ __ ]
characters weren't very interesting the
bad guys we're a bunch of [ __ ] insane
clowns there's like kind of like
something out of a Rob Zombie flick they
were supposed to be like that they
supposed to be like a different species
it did I they know I couldn't really
make any anything out of this movie it's
just it was just very low quality the
only thing that this movie had going for
is a had girls in it I was gonna say
tits yet now they were older than
[ __ ] normally what you would expect
you know I mean they were mostly in
their 40s if you ask me these are these
weren't they when you say they were in
their 40s well maybe 30 so usually for a
throwback kind of flick usually late
teens early 20s yeah you get another 19
yeah but they're probably their 30s or
40s and I'm gonna say they were you know
they were they were okay looking the
only one that stood out was the little
blog with the square head she kind of
reminded me of dams she kind of stole
the movie she was really the only thing
in the movie that was worth she was the
only one that was like a really good
actress like you know it for certain
terms so she was the only one that I
believed like as an idea person like as
an actual cat reminded me of Siobhan
Fahey she does like yeah she didn't look
that bad I said actually no that you
mentioned that yeah that's one of the
girls from Bananarama yeah she's in
Shakespeare's sister Shakespeare sister
yeah yeah
um she looked like that and she takes
her clothes off - no not really anything
special those just it's like most half
the movie is like girls running around
topless or around them like their
underwear like bras and panties yeah and
they're we're not talking about 80s
[ __ ] silicone sister bombshells or
anything either they're just ready
they're just like regular a regular
good-looking girl
right but not a draw really for a movie
you're not talking about Lana Quigley
[ __ ] they're inert in the height of
her [ __ ] baby and I'm talking about
Brecon you know a Elvira or anything you
know with the cleavage you know it's
just regular good-looking girls but it's
not enough to support this story and
they're trying to be funny and tried to
be fun but the movies actually just
tedious is [ __ ] this is the first time I
think we've given a movie a really
really bad review I think in it probably
and yeah well because I mean I'm all for
like bad movies and low-budget movies
and stuff like that if they're done like
it but I even kind of like found some
chuckles in we do shark yeah even though
I think that you know they could have
like step that up a little bit too but
this one I don't know it's like one I
guess the killer shark the killer Klown
idea is kind of played I'm not like a
big killer Klown movie person although I
will mention now that we're talking
about clown killer clown movies there
was one that came out
Oh 2013 I want to say 2014 and it was
just called clown and it wasn't so much
about a killer clown but it was about a
guy that put on a clown suit that was
actually the skin of a demon called the
coin and it turned you into a clown and
then started eating children now that
one I was was very very entertaining
it's a very gory also that other one
that weird ass [ __ ] clown that was
killing people what was it called
which one Tara fire Tara fire was great
that was a good one to terrify art the
clown clown yeah yeah okay gotta answer
some question yes that is a Frazetta
we'd not mentioned in the beginning the
show our friend Sophie gave that to me
for my birthday
yeah and it's a canvas on on
frame it's for Zeva it looks really cool
it looks very very nice flick it up
close it's not a poster first I'll
probably get it framed and it's called
the barbarian of course it's it's a
portrait of tom toms asses that's Ginny
on a [ __ ] mountain of skulls she's
for her um I should add about this this
movie clown fear well because the thing
about it was that I was scrolling
through and I was like I wasn't like
super jazzed about watching us cuz like
I said I'm not a big killer Klown movie
person but the title of it was like so
dumb that it almost turned around and
became funny to me again like I was like
clown fear I was like what was clown on
we taken clown hatred clap you know what
I mean so I was trying to think of like
all these other I was like clown fear is
like that's so stupid it's almost
awesome
so know Sandra says when Tom says that
the girls were nothing special he means
they were too thin well their boobs were
too small yeah yeah it's generally not a
shape yeah I like our I like a full kind
of hourglass bigger big legs big boobs
you know like ascetic girls yeah just go
look at Frank pizzetta's paintings and
that I think people should look like
that actually the man - nice big round
biscuit buns you know what I mean yeah
women but yeah so let's so let's talk a
little bit here's a fun fact when I
actually like read a couple reviews of
this movie was that the girl that played
like the main character the one with the
wedding dress I think her name was Carly
or Carly or something like that
that woman was one of the co
screenwriters and she wrote it with
someone else who directed it she and
directed but she was one of the she
wrote the script so what the premise of
this movie is there was a premise to
this move there was India there's a
premise to pretty much every movie
was that you got this woman named Carly
who's like the main character and she is
at this Las Vegas you know one of those
cheesy Las Vegas wedding chapels and
she's marrying her kind of you know
[ __ ] boyfriend or whatever and
there's a best man there she's got like
three bridesmaids the groom-to-be is
being kind of like a [ __ ] calling
all his you know his hottest like wife
two B's friends [ __ ] and all this I'm
like that seems a little
counterproductive but whatever and then
he ya the dialogues very clunky it is
and it's like then he like misinterprets
like some text that she got sort of and
that's like you know you bet you cheated
on me and then they like break up and
then so the girls all take off across
the desert to go to some spa to like get
over their grief or whatever and they
end up at this hotel motel called the
clown in where everything is clown
themed as you would expect because that
would be weird if it was called the
clown in and then it had another theme
this is about the time I'm actually
starting to check out of this movie well
I think it was because well honestly the
opening scene with the clown people yeah
and that that was even too much what cuz
I think it was too over-the-top like it
seemed to try hard like everyone seemed
like they were putting on funny voices
are like funny badass kind of voices yes
something yeah it's just you know saying
horrible acting and they're showing the
the villains right off the bat you
should never do that in a movie it's
like showing the shark in the first
scene don't do that yeah there's really
they gave the film's too much screen
time and because they're they're not
great characters really so the more
they're on the screen the less menacing
they are yeah they're not menacing at
all actually
well no it's just a bad movie and like
you said I think the problem - I mean
well it has a lot of problems but is
that the scenes just go on too long too
long that edit like I said they used
everything that they shot and it had a
huge cast which makes me think that he
we put everybody's friend in the movie
and we couldn't cut every we could
cut all their scenes out so everybody
got a scene the scene was a little too
long
most of the scenes didn't mean anything
to the story they didn't have to be
there the movie really should have been
trimmed down to about 35 minutes it
should have been a short film it should
have been a short cut which you know it
might have been more and enjoyable that
way
there were honestly it's currently an
ally actually looked like a movie to get
good because it seemed like the last
part of it like where they had the
circus with all the people there and
like the knife-throwing and stuff it's
like it seems like that was kind of the
whole you know where they put most of
the effort and then like they tried to
like make a movie around that Leo set
pieces and that set and that's what the
trailer was yeah that's which is why I
got you but yeah that's the thing it's
like so so I'm talking about like you
know this this woman who goes you know
through the whole movie and this you
know wedding dress that makes her boots
look all saggy and um she's like so the
the scene would not understand the art
of this scene in the in the wedding
chapel which is clearly just like you
know a room that they've like made to
look like a cheap wedding chapel it's
like you know they were trying to make
it funny they returned like the guy that
was playing the priest was he looked a
little bit like pat I thought it was pat
sajak for a second but I guess it wasn't
it looks kind of like Pat Sajak like he
had a couple of like sort of chuckle
worthy lines but that scene just seemed
to go on forever we were just like
sitting there going hopefully God like
when is what are the clouds gonna start
telling people it's like hurry up but
you know what I mean and then you know
they'd be scenes like you know with the
guy like the groom like you know goes
after like after he finds out that she
wasn't cheating and all this other stuff
so he goes like after them to find them
and then like there's this whole scene
where like his best friend gets killed
or you know the groomsmen or whatever
and then like he's there's just the
scene of him like you know swearing like
in the desert that's like faded into one
of those like what a ghetto but again
that just goes on forever yeah
every every scene every scene has way
too much dialogue in it if it's
something that can be resolved in about
four sentences between three people
they're gonna scratch that [ __ ] out to
about [ __ ] ten sentences for seven
people too much of it was a game much
like I'm talking yeah too much it was in
the daytime movies are about showing not
talking or telling you no show don't
tell and it's Vagan it that really
bogged the movie it really did seem very
long and I mean I don't need that and
I'm just saying an hour and 49 minutes
that is really long for like a B horror
movie in general like I said you know
maybe a prestige or a movie or one that
has like a more complicated story can
get away with being long but a movie
like this cannot get away with being
that oh there's the one scene in the
very beginning where all three of the
women are packed inside this car and
they look artificially very close to one
another inside this car yeah they're
like an ominous and I'm you know units
being shot from the hood and I've
realized that's not a real car that's
either that or they're just yeah it was
it was either a fake car it was just
like a really tiny car and it wasn't me
yeah it wasn't moving and then behind
them you know and in the rear a [ __ ]
window just see a white cloth with a
light shining on it there's no there's
no moving back well somebody I didn't
notice this because like I said I kind
of was like you know half paying
attention something else at the same
time but somebody I've read another
review of it and somebody mentioned not
that same but the scene where the were
the groom and his friend were in the car
yeah they said that the guy like threw
an empty beer can not the one you could
hear it hit the street as though the car
was it was a woman right yes you know I
mean so it's like I didn't notice that
but like one of the reviews like pointed
that out which you know like I said I I
hate to like [ __ ] on people for making
like low-budget movies because a lot of
low-budget movies that I've seen I've
really liked them and you know it seems
like you can do a lot with a low-budget
kind of if you know what you're doing
but I do feel like this wasn't one like
I said I'm kind of over the whole killer
Klown saying and you know and and I'm
not saying that a good movie couldn't be
made from that
but I just think there was too much
other stuff like too much extraneous
yeah stuff going on there were too many
cast members to which I think just
everybody's friends were in it yeah I
think anybody was a professional actor
yeah I mean a couple of them that I
looked up had been in like other
low-budget movies like from these
similar you know so it's not like
they're completely I think the problem
with the movie is that there's just no
artistic vision to this movie that's
really what it was yeah if he had if it
you could probably save this movie and
edit but you'd have to have kind of an
artistic vision yep you'd have to be
willing to get rid of a lot of scenes
yeah and a lot of people and what you'd
end up with this maybe about 40 minutes
I think probably and well like I said I
think I dozed off at some point so I
don't even know what happened to that
now I will say certain things certain
scenes those are just the way they're
shot look very television yeah some of
those cemetery scenes where they're
trying to run from the [ __ ] bad guys
it just didn't that was just didn't come
off like cinema yeah I get what you're
saying like they don't really have it
yeah it didn't really have and like I
said that can work to your advantage if
you're doing it on purpose or if you
could because you know I keep bringing
up like vilasa pasture which had like a
really low budget it was great but yeah
but they knew what they were doing and
they were using that to their advantage
whereas this one just seemed like they
were trying to make like another killer
Klown movie philosoph aster actually had
elements of shot composition in it it
did yeah yeah I mean this didn't there
was just there is no it was not an
artistically she was not shot
artistically yeah even though philosoph
Esther had some shitty shots it was
still artistic because it was self-aware
yeah why is it new what it what it was
like they're playing whatever they're
playing some kind of sport and somebody
gets eaten by the bullet but [ __ ]
dinosaur and the camera is obviously
being held by hand and it zooms industry
away and it just looks so it just but
you busting up laughing yeah just with
that
on camera pan and it was just because in
a lot of ways you have tonight kind of
learned this when I was a kid in my art
class when we were talking about you
know kind of non representational art
and how you know you see something like
for example like a Willem de Kooning or
a Jackson Pollock or something like that
it's like oh well I can do that but the
thing about it is that you kind of have
to know like all the alternatives or all
the artistic rules before you can go
about breaking random and it the same
thing happens with film it's like
there's a difference between a film that
looks amateurish on purpose that's made
by people that know about film and are
doing that as an artistic choice and
that's done by people that don't know
any better
yeah and also like in the Edit there has
to be a certain herb and a flow and a
rhythm to things and that's just that's
not here this movie is just there you
know I mean it does there is no rhythm
driving this movie along yeah there's no
tempo too and there wasn't even there
wasn't a lot of gore that I remember um
you know some of the conversations
between like some of the women and stuff
worth were kind of funny but not in the
way that I mean oh thank you Matt thanks
but not in the way that that it was like
a comedy and I think it was supposed to
be a comedy because it says on the
poster like you'll die laughing or
something like that but it's like it
wasn't even really all that funny you
know what I mean yeah it wasn't like
cringy but it was just kind of like yeah
I was gonna say something about the
humor the humor was very forced and it
was and it didn't come across as
spontaneous so there wasn't any
spontaneity in the humor the humor
itself was kind of yeah it's a good word
I can't really think of the word um - I
know I know what you're getting at but I
can't really like kind of childish humor
yeah I guess that's not exactly right
but yeah they were worthless kind of
sophomoric kind of kind of I don't know
just it was a very clever yeah you know
the one mundane the one thing I will say
that I did like was the
design I don't know if this is a real
place that they shot at I hope it isn't
but um the clown in like the insides of
the rooms where they were they filmed it
like this clown themed motel that
actually looked pretty cool like with
the beds and like the checkerboard walls
and floor and how the bathtub had like
this clown you know kind of spigot
coming out and there was even the foam
was shaped like a clown everything like
that so somebody like if the production
design team or like the set design team
actually made that then you know good on
you because that looked actually pretty
cool yeah and it looks and they really
like went the extra mile like to find
all the clown themed a little tchotchkes
that they could find and like stick in
there and like I said this might be a
real place but I don't know if it is or
not I wanna you know what they say you
don't don't like to [ __ ] on [ __ ]
people's movies and stuff you know I
mean I think I think there's potential
for this director it just I think then I
think the movie I think the movie could
have really been improved a lot by a
better edit yeah for being shorter right
um I think edit was the problem a lot of
it I think I think a really slick edit
on this thing would have really picked
up the tempo picture the pace of the
movie and it would have been been more
enjoyable to watch yeah and I think
comes across as a movie made by a bunch
of friends so they could watch it yeah
you know for a person who's not who
doesn't know yeah first isn't in the
movie it's just yes I got it I got a
feeling that some of the reviews like it
had a lot of positive reviews I think
those people were in the movie I think
that happens a lot especially with these
smaller ya like or people are like you
know make a burner account or like have
your mom go on there yeah everybody rate
the movie real good review it and stuff
and like we said I don't say it doesn't
bring me any joy to do that it's just
that I feel like and I think we brought
this up on you know the ouija shark
review and probably the velociter one as
well it's like if you're making a
low-budget movie just
ramp up the ridiculousness yeah to the
breakfast this the premise of this just
wasn't ridiculous enough right I would
look at velociter that way that's a good
with just the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] you
can think of it make it like just the
ridiculous most stupid over-the-top just
go way over the top of it look a little
bit at some old some old carpenter
flakes you know he did a lot with a very
little and you know see what you can do
that was just edit has a lot to do with
the tempo the tempo of the pace I think
yeah I think that was really kind of the
main problem with this was that it was
just too long and like a lot of the
scenes just went on too long and we're
not necessary to the store um for you
know so like I said some of the acting
was fine like particularly that one girl
that was in it that played one of the
bridesmaids I think she was like the
maid of honor or whatever I came from
her character's name was but she was
like I mean she was noticeably like much
a much better actor than pretty much
everyone else I think I would have just
trimmed the movie way down to a simple
survivor survival horror flick with a
group with a group of females not really
had a real complicated story then just
had a bunch of cool gags as a humor in
it yeah and I think it would've been
more effective there's just too much
goddamn movie in here yeah it's like I
said that's that's just trying it
anyone's patience like she make it that
long I mean [ __ ] like I think the Lassa
faster was only like an hour and five
minutes ten minutes and they didn't
where it's welcome out you know it's
like it was already over like I wanted
more of it it's better to like have
people wanting like it to be longer than
like sitting there wishing that it would
be shorter I'm just I don't know it's
like I'm kind of like I'm not a
moviemaker so you know I am a writer but
you know I don't know a huge amount
about filmmaking but I always feel like
if I was gonna make a horror movie and I
had you know however many thousand
dollars that I've raised on Kickstarter
or whatever well what I would do for one
thing I would not go I just I wouldn't
make a killer clown movie I wouldn't
make a killer shark movie I wouldn't
make a Ouija board maybe I wouldn't make
a cabin in the woods type movie I
wouldn't make anything like that because
that's been done a million times it's
like I would rather come up with at
least something that was sort of
original or an original take on
something else
or like I said I would just make it as
like think of this weirdest like most
ridiculous thing I could think of
because then you get attention
I mean velociter got attention because
it was just a crazy concept that nobody
had done before it was a dinosaur
kung-fu movie and what else
there was a hooker and a hooker in it
yeah there was ninjas hooker yeah and a
police that turned into a dynamited be
like wasn't that video game called buff
dudes but that's the thing it's like um
an 80s fighting video game buff dudes
taken to the [ __ ] screen dinosaurs
and hookers [ __ ] ridiculous cuz I
just feel like I feel like if you're
making a low-budget movie you had
there's so much competition especially
nowadays like now that you know
moviemaking you know equipment is like
so cheap and you can make a movie with
your [ __ ] iPhone for Christ's sakes
that looks you know almost as good as
like other independent movies so I just
feel like why on earth would you waste
you know have $35,000 or however much
you know the movie cost to make why
would you want to make another killer
clown movie why would you wanna make
another demon-possession movie it's not
gonna stand out because everybody and
their mother has already made one of
those and it's like unless you have a
new angle on it which I guarantee that
you probably do not because everything
has pretty much been done be like trying
to make another zombie movie I mean
you're pregnant yeah exactly that's like
you know you're probably just not gonna
succeed because it's just gonna like get
lost in the morass of like the jelly
movies the zillions of other ones some
of which might be perfectly fine and
perfectly watchable but if you want
something that is just gonna rise above
the pack you either have to make
something really original or you have to
make something so [ __ ] wacky and funny
that people are just gonna take notice
of it right away
yeah and you have to have a comedian
involved in that so I hit the right
humor that yeah that's a I feel like if
you're trying to make a horror comedy
you don't don't just realize like well
I'm thinking I can I think I'm funny
yeah it's like that I think I'm funny
I'm like Garrity you're probably the
only one
it's like you know you run the [ __ ] by
some other people like some actual funny
people before you go into that but yeah
so oh my goodness she's like busted out
I don't really have any more to say
about it yeah I can't I can't recommend
it it's it's not even like one of those
you know so bad it's a good type of
thing just like I said the premise of it
just isn't crazy enough ends up just
being kind of tedious yeah it was just
kind of long and it's just you know I I
was kind of spacing out then I think I
fell asleep at some point a lot happens
in it most of it doesn't have to happen
and it's not you're not really was
seeing much yeah that's kind of what's
obvious about yeah I've never gone I'm
not gonna let you pick that one
the trailer was good it was it tells me
that edit has a lot to do with it yeah I
guess the trailer actually looked like
it might be like it maybe cuz I thought
it was gonna go like I said like maybe
like a Rob Zombie direction or I thought
I was gonna go like that like that movie
that was just called clown about that
clown Damon which that would have been
awesome cuz that was a really good I
thought it was gonna be kind of like
that horror movie we saw they were they
were at that horror theme park how best
like Hellfest yeah yeah just me
something kinda like that that was
actually pretty decent than it had any
any right today cuz it was a decent
movie yeah it was yeah alright so um yes
founder said they made a movie about a
killer rubber tire
yeah it's called rubber that one um I
haven't seen that but I watched like a
big four summaries and I was like
scrolling through like YouTube and
somebody had done like kind of a long
like breakdown of the movie because
apparently it's kind of like a meta like
a weird existential that's like or movie
which I didn't expect
and I'm like well no I kind of want to
see it it's kind of like but this one
kind of bummed me out the same way that
death bed the bed that eats bummed me
out because I'm like with a title like
that I was expecting it to be much
weirder and much funnier much wackier
mundane and it just wasn't it just
wasn't it's like it's it was just really
boring mostly and it's just like with a
premise like that you really got a
[ __ ] whoo he's getting into the
shirts leaning into the [ __ ] yeah we got
the shipment of the blank shirts
yesterday and Pookie is just she loves
him she just cannot get enough
of that box and she's just like trying
to open it with her face keep busting
alright so uh that's it for today I
guess we will probably do another
livestream probably on Saturday and
maybe another one on Sunday like I said
I want to after I finish watching dark
all the way through like the end of
season 3 I want to talk about that as
well but I just got to the end of season
1 so I'll use the rest of the week to
watch season 2 and 3 and then we'll have
a discussion about that so we will see
you guys on Saturday thanks for dropping
by
and thanks everybody for donating that
donated and we'll see you later bye